es ist wirklich absolut seltsam wenn man
gegen dieses schwarz blick dann blickt
man ins nichts absolut nichts ist zu
erkennen es wirkt wie aus einer anderen
welt aber es ist von der erde
walter black das absolut dunkelste
schwarz der welt allerdings keine farbe
sondern eine beschichtung aus
kohlenstoff-nanoröhrchen die nahezu das
komplette licht schlucken und damit
gegenstände unerkennbar macht ihr habt
euch dieses thema bei whatsapp gewünscht
und bekommt jetzt die wichtigsten facts
wie funktioniert diese besondere
beschichtung warum steht die kunstszene
kopf jetzt mal klicks um science-fiction
herzlich willkommen
in der fachsprache lautet der name
vertical alignment you pay also vantaa
kurz und bedeutet in etwa so viel wie
senkrecht angeordneten nanoröhren raster
und tatsächlich bei walter black handelt
es sich nicht um eine farbe oder ein
segment sondern um eine beschichtung aus
carbon nanotubes cnt es also kohlenstoff
nanoröhrchen tatsächlich aber und das
klingt erst mal kurios besteht die
beschichtung zum großteil gar nicht
ausnahme röhrchen sondern aus frei im
raum der dazwischen liegt und genau
diese zwischenräume sorgen für dieses
extreme schwarz denn das licht das auf
die nanoröhrchen feld verschwindet ihnen
diesen zwischenräumen und wird
absorbiert und weil so eben nur sehr
wenig licht reflektiert wird erscheint
uns wandte black so unheimlich schwarz
auf der hersteller webseite gibt es dazu
das folgende szenario das den effekt
ganz gut beschreibt stellt euch vor ihr
lauft durch einen dichten dichten wald
ganz viele stämme dann sticht die bäume
sind aber nicht 20 meter hoch sondern
3000 meter und das licht das dann noch
unten ankommt an dem auf dem waldboden
das ist kaum noch wahrnehmen war weil es
dazwischen eben geschluckt wird und wenn
überhaupt gut erkennen kann man das auch
an einem stück alufolie in deren mitte
sich ein stück wand black befindet
verknittert doch das nimmt das
menschliche auge nicht wahr die falten
sind nicht mehr sichtbar
dafür sieht es fast so aus wie ein
schwarzes loch laut herstellerangaben
absorbiert wand tablett 99,96 fünf der
lichtmenge und ich finde dass diese
super schwarz so wirkt als seien objekte
stümperhaft mit einem
bildbearbeitungsprogramm wegradiert aber
das eben in wirklichkeit die carbon
nanotubes haben jeweils einen
durchmesser von 20 nanometern und sind
zwischen 14 und 50 mühl lang eine
milliarde kohlenstoff nanoröhrchen sind
etwa auf einem quadratzentimeter
verteilt allerdings hat das
gesamtvolumen also der materie darin der
nano welche nur einen anteil von 0 05
prozent an der gesamten beschichtung das
ist echt ein quadratmeter wiegt gerade
mal zweieinhalb
ein echtes wunder material also stellt
euch mal vor welche gruseligen kahn als
oder halloween kostüme man sich damit
bauen könnte leider ist es aber nicht
wirklich für uns endverbraucher
erhältlich und abgesehen davon dass
diese beschichtung nicht gerade günstig
ist eigentlich wurde sie für
militärische zwecke und bestimmte
anwendung in der raumfahrt entwickelt
wie etwa teleskope denn die
eigenschaften der beschichtung sind
wirklich mehr als beeindruckend die
kohlenstoff nanoröhrchen sind extrem
unempfindlich vor allem gegenüber
temperaturschwankungen oder starken
erschütterung aber achtung bei direkter
mechanischer belastung also selbst ein
fingerabdruck würde es zerstören und so
muss das material vor direktem kontakt
geschützt werden auf geschieht durch
eine schutzschicht oder glas weil walter
black ja aber wie gesagt so extrem das
licht absorbiert wird die beschichtung
mittlerweile auch sehr gerne in der
sensor und messtechnik und bei infrarot
kameras eingesetzt aber auch in der
kunstszene weiß man die eigenschaften
von manta black zu schätzen anfang 2016
hat sich der britische künstler anish
kapoor die rechte gesichert selbst zum
ärger seiner kolleginnen und kollegen
körper macht jetzt kulturen constanta
black was absolut irre aussieht da man
ja keine schatten oder reflexe sieht
sind erhebungen und vertiefungen nur
erkennbar und das auch nur schwer wenn
man um sie herum geht wenn er als erstes
neues zum thema nanotechnologie und zu
allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann
endet meine telefonnummer hierbei
whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor
allen anderen vom neuesten video
garantiert unsere begrüßung habe ich
noch eine kleine überraschung für euch
einfach hier draufklicken und schon geht
es los und natürlich nicht das aber mit
der genaue glocke vergessen hier geht es
weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
wissenschaftlicher durchbruch in zwölf
millionen dimensionen ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran